On September 6th, 2019, the 95-year-old former
president of Zimbabwe Robert Mugabe died of
cancer.
He did not, however, die in Zimbabwe.
Instead, Mugabe chose to receive his medical
care, as he always did, in Singapore — a
whole 5,000 miles or 8,000 kilometers away.
Each of his many such trips required no fewer
than 10 hours in the air each way, by which
time he could’ve flown anywhere in continental
Europe.
The African revolutionary was not the only
powerful person to seek treatment in this
southeast Asian city-state of just five million.
So too did the daughter of the Philippines
president, the president of Bangladesh, several
military leaders of Myanmar, and the former
first lady of Indonesia, to name just a few
examples.
Heads of state no doubt appreciate Singapore’s
tight control of the press and lack of protestors,
though their first priority is surely the
same as its other 500,000 annual medical tourists
— to receive what is perhaps the best healthcare
on earth.
Today the average Singaporean lives to be
an astonishing 83 years old — a full decade
longer than the world average, and only slightly
behind Switzerland, Macau, Japan, Hong Kong,
and San Marino.
Another common metric for healthcare quality
is the infant mortality rate, at which Singapore
is among the best in the world — just 2.1
for every 1,000 live births.
Finally, Bloomberg ranked the country second
in overall efficiency.
These are impressive outcomes on their own,
but they become downright amazing when you
consider how little they cost.
The United States spends about 17% of its
GDP on healthcare — making it an embarrassing
outlier even among the most developed nations.
The UK, a more representative example, stands
at 10%, Australia, 9, and Israel, just 8.
Singapore, on the other hand, spends just
four percent of GDP.
This is, in fact, lower than the minimum recommended
by the World Health Organization. On this
metric, Singapore is surrounded by poor countries
like Sudan, Eritrea, and Madagascar.
If you didn’t know of its world-class outcomes,
you’d assume, based on this number, that
it must surely be a struggling backwater,
not a thriving global finance hub.
If the US spent the same proportion of its
GDP on healthcare, it could afford, with those
savings, to permanently finance 139 of the
world’s smallest countries. It could save
three times the entire cost of the American
military.
Somehow Singapore provides the same or even
better healthcare than the richest countries
in the world at the cost of the poorest countries
in the world.
In designing healthcare systems, governments
willfully chose at most two of the following:
Price, quality, or equal access. They do so
because they accept these “natural” trade-offs
— believing that you can’t have it all.
Singapore, on the other hand, seems to have
solved this M. C. Escher-level puzzle and
delivered all three.
Sponsored by CuriosityStream and Nebula — where
you can watch the extended version of this
video.
When Singapore gained independence in 1965,
healthcare was far from its highest priority.
In the words of its health minister at the
time, it ranked at most fifth — after national
security, jobs, housing, and education.
Facing an uncertain future and with the country’s
very existence at stake, the government had
no choice but to ration its attention and
resources.
The U.S. performed its first successful kidney
transplant in the early 1950s. But Singapore
would have to wait twenty years to do the
same.
With just 50 specialists for a population
of two million, it chose to focus first on
more pressing issues, like the rampant spread
of tuberculosis and pneumonia.
This slow and methodical approach helped the
country develop a set of guiding, foundational
principles which informed its decision-making.
While Singapore was still a British colony
in 1948 when the English National Health Service
was created, it chose a very different path.
In fact, if there’s one philosophy that
defines its national approach to healthcare,
it’s a firm and unapologetic rejection of
what was perceived as the over-generosity
of the British.
Believing that the general public was abusing,
misusing, and under-appreciating government
clinics, its first Prime Minister, Lee Kuan
Yew was quick to impose a fee.
It was decided that while every citizen would
be guaranteed some form of care, nothing would
be strictly free, motivating a sense of personal
responsibility.
But allergic as the government was to anything
resembling “welfare”, it also had little
confidence individuals could be trusted to
manage their own healthcare savings.
The compromise to this tension was called
“MediSave”.
The British had left Singapore with a compulsory
savings account known as the Central Provident
Fund.
It required employees to deposit 5% of their
income, which employers matched, to be withdrawn
at retirement.
Over the years, Lee raised these contribution
rates and introduced several new components.
Today, the average Singaporean is required
to stash away about a third of their income
into three accounts.
The first — the “Ordinary Account” — can
be used to pay for things like school and
housing.
A second “Special Account” is reserved
for retirement, and merges with the Ordinary
Account at age 55.
Finally, the MediSave account can be used
for medical care and insurance.
In essence, every citizen is required to stash
away some money for a rainy day.
Most income at the beginning of one’s career
is directed to the Ordinary Account, which
is one of the reasons so many Singaporeans
can afford their own home.
As you approach retirement, more and more
of your money is sent to MediSave.
And when the government runs a budget surplus,
it often simply deposits the difference directly
into these accounts, ensuring it’s put to
good use.
In practice, the system functions neither
like American social security, nor a fully
self-owned bank account. It’s somewhere
in-between, which makes it somewhat controversial.
On one hand, the government likes to boast
that citizens own their own funds. In some
sense, this is true. It’s not attached to
your employer, and thus doesn’t end if you’re
fired or laid off. The money it contains is
completely tax-free and can be willed away,
like any property, at death.
It’s also guaranteed a minimum, competitive,
interest rate between 2.5 and 5%.
On the other hand, critics highlight how restrictive
it is.
Funds are subject to both a minimum and maximum
balance, periodic limits, and deliberately
designed not to fully cover any single medical
expense, which the government argues would
eliminate personal responsibility.
In other words, it’s entirely possible someone
could go broke from exorbitant medical bills
despite having plenty in their MediSave account
— for no other reason than the government
prohibits them from using it all.
Every day of hospitalization, procedure, and
treatment has a maximum proportion that can
be paid for by MediSave — the rest is simply
out of pocket.
In 1990, the Singapore government addressed
this inadequacy and introduced what they had
been trying to avoid — insurance.
MediShield Life, as it’s now known, is intended
as a defense against only the most catastrophic
of conditions involving long-term treatment,
like dialysis or cancer therapy.
Even then, it activates only after patients
have contributed a significant portion either
out of pocket or via their MediSave account.
But it’s very affordable.
A 20-year-old, for example, pays just $101
US Dollars a year, which can even be paid
for with MediSave.
Each age group pays however much is needed
to make it independently sustainable. In other
words, it’s not simply a transfer of wealth
from the young to the old, like the American
pyramid scheme known as “Social Security”.
Because of this, older people pay much higher
premiums. $509 a year, for example, for those
aged 90 or older.
Still, MediShield is generally well-liked.
Though compulsory today, more people participated
when it was voluntary than in the U.S., three
years after ObamaCare was made mandatory — 94%
to 91.
Those who want more comprehensive insurance
have the option of buying upgraded plans from
private companies, all of which are tightly
regulated to ensure competition.
Finally, in 1993, Singapore stepped in with
a safety net of last resort for the lowest-income
households.
MediFund is a principal-protected, and thus
indefinitely sustainable, endowment which
pays for the medical care of those who can’t.
Any citizen who can prove their inability
to pay can apply to a group of independent
volunteers who make case-by-case judgments.
Most applications are approved within 30 minutes,
but the most complicated of cases can take
up to three weeks.
In 2019, MediFund paid $120 million involving
over a million applications.
These three “M’s” — MediSave, MediShield,
and MediFund, are often cherry-picked by those
seeking to reform healthcare abroad. Some
point to the mandatory savings accounts as
evidence healthcare shouldn’t be handed
out for “free”. Others protest that MediFund
is the real backbone of the system.
In truth, neither is completely accurate.
Each of the three M’s is one layer of protection
— without which the entire system wouldn’t
function.
But don’t get the wrong impression. The
bulk of healthcare spending still takes the
form of subsidies.
In 2013, MediSave, MediShield, and Medifund
accounted for 5.1, 2.1, and 0.8% of all healthcare
expenditures, respectively.
What’s revolutionary about the 3Ms, however,
is not how large they are, but how they control
costs for everyone — including taxpayers.
Singapore solves the American problem in which
hospitals are incentivized to charge exorbitant
prices which are merely passed on to insurance
companies.
Because patients pay more out of pocket, hospitals
are forced to control costs. These lower costs
are passed on to the government, too, when
it distributes subsidies.
In other words, while the sticker price may
feel higher for Singaporeans, the total amount
they pay, both out-of-pocket and in taxes,
is far, far lower.
All of this is enabled by transparency. The
government makes all costs public and easily
accessible online. Hospitals are required
to provide patients with an estimate of their
bill, as well as the average cost at competing
hospitals.
But how, you may ask, are these subsidies
distributed? What system could possibly ensure
that the poor get support while the rich don’t
abuse it?
For the most part, people just sort themselves.
Public hospital rooms are split into four
classes: C, B2, B1, and A.
The cheapest, Class C, have 8-10 beds in a
fairly utilitarian room, while the most expensive,
Class A, are private rooms with a TV and Air
Conditioning.
The important thing is these classes are treated
as cosmetic, luxury upgrades. The same doctors
operate all wards with the same standards
of care. They have no monetary incentive to
treat anyone differently.
And much like airplane classes, more premium
rooms cost significantly more with only modest
improvements, which naturally separates patients
based on their willingness to pay.
Is it fair that the poor sit in a stuffy,
crowded room during hot, humid summers? Answers
will vary, but many would argue the alternative:
high prices for everyone, is worse.
In fact, so many patients were content choosing
lower classes than they could afford, that
hospitals eventually introduced means-testing.
Anyone, with any income, can choose whatever
room they prefer, but subsidies vary both
based on ward class and income.
Class A rooms, for example, offer no subsidy,
while class C are subsidized up to 80%.
For all these reasons, Singapore defies categorization.
Is it a free-market, or is it centrally planned?
Yes.
In theory, hospitals are welcome to charge
whatever, and yet the entire market is tightly
controlled by the government, who, in regulating
everything from MediSave minimum contributions,
to what qualifies for MediShield, can influence
whatever outcome it wishes.
Is it public or private? Yes.
20% of primary care and 80% of secondary is
public, but the two are expressly designed
to work in concert.
The system is not perfect.
One challenge is that MediSave heavily relies
on families who pool together costs for major
operations.
In 2010, for example, 44% of withdrawals were
made for a family member. For example, someone’s
child, spouse, or parent.
Today, however, the average Singaporean woman
has just 1.15 children in her lifetime — the
third lowest fertility rate in the world — meaning
the population is rapidly shrinking.
As the country gets older, it will experience
significantly more chronic and complex illnesses,
yet smaller families will mean fewer people
can pool savings.
Solving healthcare is an ongoing process.
But Singapore can credibly say that it has
paved a new, third path. Some countries offer
medicine free-at-the-point-of-care, which
results in long queues, others simply don’t
guarantee healthcare at all, and therefore
have to leave behind the most vulnerable.
Singapore, on the other hand, does neither.
The million-dollar question is whether Singapore
is a strange anomaly or a viable model for
the rest of the world? Could this system work
in the United States, for example?
That’s the question we explore in the extended
version of this video on Nebula, which replaces
what you’re hearing right now with more
of this video.
Just about every other video, in fact, has
bonus or extended content available on Nebula,
which is the streaming site I, and other educational
YouTubers created to host new and experimental
content.
I wanted to open my video about China’s
National Insecurity, for instance, with a
dramatic contrast between the welcoming China
of ten years ago with today’s aggressive
China, but realized it would most likely get
demonetized on YouTube. So instead, you can
watch it, in its full, intended form, along
with a bonus video about next year’s Beijing
Olympics, on Nebula.
You can also watch entirely exclusive videos,
like my friend KentoBento’s telling of the
most insane hijacking in Japanese history,
or Neo’s beautiful “The Unknown City”.
Plus, we’ve partnered with CuriosityStream
— home to great documentaries on technology,
history, and science — like this one on
how Singapore’s billion-dollar sports stadium
was built — so that you can get it and Nebula
for less than $15 a year.
Sign up with the link in the description and
watch the extended version of this video over
on Nebula.